France in flames.
We have all seen these images.
For several days at the end of June and the
beginning of July, the French nation once again
experienced a situation of complete chaos.
The footage of protests, looting,
fire and riots that broke out in France's
major cities were seen around the world.
Of course, these images are no longer something
extraordinary in this country. Events and images,
more or less similar, are repeated every
so often and with increasing intensity.
It doesn't matter if we are talking about
racial or religious vindication and protests,
the final of the soccer "Champions
League", the yellow vests or pension
reforms. Violence is becoming a distinctive
sign of any social movement in this country.
The latest wave of riots triggered by the fatal
shooting of 17-year-old Nahel Merzouk by a
policeman resulted in more than 5,000 vehicles
burned, more than 1,000 properties damaged or
looted, 269 police stations attacked and more
than 4,000 people arrested. It was madness.
Even so, let's not fool ourselves, because
these protests will not go down in history.
In today's France, the latest wave of violence
will be just that, the last wave before the
next one comes in the not too distant future.
It is something that is bound to happen... And
it will probably happen sooner than we can
imagine. Because VisualPolitik community,
France is starting to be broken, the
country is in serious danger of implosion
and every now and then the flames rise up.
("It is as if France is a pressure cooker,
[each crisis] reveals tensions, a conflict in
society... Our country is constantly invoking
republican values, but it seems that
whole segments of the population do not
feel that this matters to them" – Bruno Cautrès,
political researcher in declarations to Politico)
The situation has reached such a
point that, during the protests,
French President Emmanuel Macron went so
far as to advocate ideas such as these:
(Macron suggests blocking social
media during riots – Le Monde)
But what exactly is going on in France?
Why does society seem completely broken?
What is behind these huge waves of violence?
What consequences are they likely to have?
VisualPolitik viewers, in this video we are going
to tell you which are the three main factors
in all this chaos that every now and then is
unleashed in France. The three major ingredients
that will allow us to better understand exactly
what is happening in France and why Paris and
other major French cities are becoming the
Gotham Cities of Europe. But in this case,
obviously there’s no Batman in sight... Although,
as we will see, some characters pretend to be.
Let's get on with it.
(THE BANLIEUES: THE FUSE)
In order to really understand this
story we have to start by going
back to the middle of the 20th century.
As in many other large cities in Europe
and America, Paris and other large French cities
were expanding at full speed. Industrialization
and the exodus from the countryside to the
city were multiplying urban populations.
In the case of France, this
phenomenon was also accelerated by the
decolonization processes of its former empire.
In response to the overcrowding of cities and the
appearance of shantytowns and substandard housing,
the suburbs of cities began to grow in the 1960s:
the famous "banlieues"
They did so in Paris,
Lyon, Marseilles and other large cities.
They were developed under the direction of
the French State itself, which began to
promote thousands and thousands, tens of
thousands of social housing units in these new
neighborhoods where, of course, schools, medical
centers and public transportation lines were
also opened. On paper the idea was fantastic.
With these new neighborhoods and the thousands
of public housing units built by the government,
the poorest French could not
only have access to a house,
but also to a much more affluent lifestyle.
However, problems soon arose. You
know that there is a massive gap
between theory and practice and that good
intentions do not guarantee good results.
Well, initially, most of the housing was
destined for the French who had emigrated
from the countryside to the city, but as soon
as they could, they moved to neighborhoods
considered better. So what happened to
those vacated State housing spaces? Well,
they were acquired by or passed into
the hands of the immigrant population.
At the same time, the deindustrialization
that Paris has experienced over the last
four decades has closed the doors to
good jobs and good salaries for many
of the residents of these same neighborhoods.
And so, in this way, these areas ended up becoming
something like a synonym of poverty,
immigration and all kinds of problems:
school dropouts, discrimination, unemployment,
poorly maintained buildings, delinquency...
Let's just say that little by little these
suburbs started to become real ghettos.
This was a particularly intense phenomenon for
many groups of immigrants from the Caribbean,
Senegal, Ivory Coast, Morocco and especially
Algeria, who have ended up living in separate
neighborhoods, where the cultural pressure of
their countries of origin is maintained and
where levels of integration with French society
are relatively low. In recent years, for example,
many people from countries such as Pakistan
have been arriving. And, as you can imagine,
the combination of such a rigid culture with
a ghetto environment is a ticking time bomb.
Now, don't think that this has
taken anyone by surprise. In 1977,
the French government was already
concerned that ghettos were forming.
What's more, in the last 20 years alone, the
French State has spent a whopping 60 billion
euros on a colossal campaign to renovate
housing blocks, improve infrastructure
and upgrade all kinds of facilities in
these neighborhoods, particularly in the
poorest ones where more than five million
people live, half of them from Algeria.
In fact, during the latest protests, I am sure you
have all seen how libraries, schools and health
centers were burned. And logically, if they
have been burned, it is because they exist.
(Health is free, school is free, and
sometimes we have the feeling that it
is never enough." – Emmanuel Macron)
On top of that, for years there have
also been lots of organizations paid by the
government to try to make things better.
Yet, despite all the efforts, the
results have been rather poor.
The banlieues are widely known for
their high rates of unemployment,
school dropouts, drug addiction, poverty
and delinquency. It is a real disaster.
Because many of the people who live
in these places, especially children,
do not have an easy time escaping from them.
And the fact is that changing material things
is relatively simple. All you have to
do is pull out your checkbook. However,
the same is not true of culture or people.
Do you want an example? Well, think of the
schools. Schools in these neighborhoods have
very high failure rates and their academic
level tends to be much lower. This means that
many students end up falling by the wayside.
Well, the fact is that this public housing policy
that ended up promoting real ghettos is one of the
key factors for explaining why France has
so many problems integrating immigrants.
Basically, immigrants arrive in France, they live
in France, their children are born in France,
but they never really become French.
Neither them nor their children. At least
not completely. Here the data are compelling.
For example, it is estimated that about 50%
of the children in these ghettos are poor.
Unemployment is almost double the national
average and, of course, family incomes are
much lower. To give you an idea, one out of
five foreigners living in France thinks they are
discriminated against because of their origin,
their race or their religion. This is one of
the highest rates in the developed world.
It turns out that France is one of the countries
that has the most problems integrating immigrants.
And these neighborhoods are largely to blame.
You don't believe me? Well...
Take a look at this graph.
("There is still a feeling in these neighborhoods,
and probably a reality, that you don't have
as many opportunities as in other places,
when you see your parents and older siblings
struggling to find work. [...] We are paying
for the concentration of poverty, the lack of
diversity in the schools and the refusal to
build social housing outside these neighborhoods"
– Olivier Klein, Minister of Housing and Urban
Affairs and former mayor of Clichy-sous-Bois, a
municipality in the eastern suburbs of Paris)
Logically, all these factors generate
frustration. And, make no mistake, frustration
is the best possible fuel for violence.
To make matters worse, two new problems have
arisen in these neighborhoods in recent years:
Firstly, drug trafficking.
(Cocaine supply at an all-time
high in France – LeMonde)
Drug consumption in France has grown a
lot in recent years. It is estimated that
cocaine alone has more than 600,000 regular
users in France. This has obviously led to
the emergence of many underworld groups that
operate precisely from these neighborhoods.
At the same time, there is the problem of
religious fundamentalism. It is precisely
in these types of suburbs that most of the
Muslim population of France lives. And,
think about it, the lack of opportunities, the
feeling of not belonging and the frustration
have formed the perfect breeding ground
when it comes to recruiting fanatics.
For example, I don't know if you remember, but
before the pandemic, jihadist attacks in France
were the order of the day. Well, most of them
were perpetrated by people of Algerian origin who
lived, guess where? Exactly, in the banlieues.
This has logically contributed to an enormous
spiral of distrust, violence and suspicion that
has only exacerbated the problem. For example,
people of foreign origin living in these
neighborhoods are 20 times more likely
to be stopped by police. Take a moment
to process that: 20 times more likely.
Keep in mind that it’s a police force that
is not always particularly friendly. Which
brings us directly to the second
major factor in this whole story.
Listen up.
(THE POLICE: THE ACCELERANT?)
The police force is by far one of the most
powerful institutions in France. Among other
reasons because it is strongly unionized.
The police have a lot of political influence.
And in recent years the rise of jihadist
fundamentalism, the increasingly common
protests against the government of the
day and the increase in drug trafficking
has given them even more presence in society.
To give you an idea, for every year since the
beginning of the century, France has practically
passed a new security law that strengthens the
police. For example, they can use intermediate
weapons in their patrols in the suburbs, something
that is extremely rare in the rest of Europe.
Another example? They have been given the power
to stop and identify absolutely anyone they
want to without any reason whatsoever.
And their powers even include that, since 2017,
traffic police have been allowed to use lethal
force against any driver fleeing a checkpoint.
In fact, although it may surprise you, Nahel
Merzouk's case was not unprecedented. On 7 June,
just three weeks before Nahel's death, the Paris
police killed a young woman, 21 years old, who
had allegedly refused to stop at a checkpoint.
On 14 June, two weeks before Nahel's death,
police also killed a 19-year-old delivery worker,
a Guinean boy, at another checkpoint.
In total, in just the 18 months prior to
the death that triggered the protests, the French
police had killed 17 people at traffic controls.
It was madness.
And
that's not all. In general, we are
talking about a police force that
accumulates a lot of complaints for excesses
of all kinds and that, as you can imagine,
is very unpopular in the suburbs.
And vice versa. According to polls,
police officers disproportionately
identify with parties like Marine Le Pen's,
which are calling for a much firmer hand.
In fact, after the latest riots broke out,
the two big police unions employed a tremendously
inflammatory tone. They went so far as to say
that they were at war against hordes of savages
and that they had to put an end to the rats.
Well, what can I say? You can
have whatever opinion you like,
but I don't know, statements like that don't
exactly seem likely to inspire calm, do they?
The French police are no joke.
In fact, keep in mind what Macron
himself was saying in 2017:
("I want to change the culture,
management style and recruitment of the
police force" – Emmanuel Macron in 2017)
Nevertheless, not long after came the yellow
vests, the pension reform protests and so
on... And naturally, Macron wanted nothing
to do with fighting with the police... And
especially not with his unions.
It was the last thing he needed!
Of course, the fact that the police are
incapable of controlling the suburbs and
that the population of these neighborhoods has so
little confidence in them only adds fuel to the
problem of the ghettos that we have already seen.
But hold on just a moment, because in this entire
story not everyone loses out. The third major
factor in this whole mess... It is nothing short
of the great beneficiary of this whole story.
Any ideas? Well... Stay tuned.
(CLAMOR FOR AN IRON FIST: THE CONSEQUENCE)
The latest wave of violence has resulted
in one clear winner: Marine Le Pen.
The French are starting to be fed up and Le
Pen has capitalized on the moment like no one
else. Le Pen and her party took advantage of the
riots to attack the Macron government, but also
to present a package of heavy-handed measures
intended to please the majority of voters."
For example, the National Rally, formerly
the National Front, Le Pen's party,
wants young people from 16 years old to be able
to be tried in criminal proceedings as adults,
it wants those convicted of crimes to lose the
right to live in public housing or to receive any
kind of payment or consideration from the State.
It also wants many more people to be imprisoned
and to reduce social payments to people living
in these very suburbs we are talking about.
And do you know what? All this is starting
to sound good to the French... Remember
that’s not us saying it. On 30 June a
poll was conducted which showed that Le
Pen's response has been the best rated
of all political leaders in France.
("The scum we see looting stores,
torching libraries and city halls,
all while laughing, are not doing this for
Nahel. It is an excuse to attack the police
and everything that represents the republic."
– Edwige Diaz, deputy of the National Rally)
Despite everything, support for the police
has remained quite high among the French.
According to a poll published
by the newspaper Le Figaro,
57% sided with the police, while 69%
supported declaring a state of emergency,
which was, by the way, another of Le Pen's
demands. It’s been quite a political rally.
VisualPolitik community, the breeding
ground that is emerging in France is...
Delicate. On the one hand, there is
the frustration of the suburbs, on the
other hand jihadism, then we have the most radical
parties gathering support at full speed. This is
the great threat of implosion of France. A country
where we can already find news items like this:
(Fundraiser for French officer who killed teen
raises over $1.5 million – WashingtonPost)
Of course, wait a minute, because
this is not only happening in France.
The truth is that the issue of immigration
and, above all, the integration problems that
have generated many of the policies that
have been implemented in recent decades
is becoming explosive material.
France receives a lot of attention,
but it is not a unique case.
Here on VisualPolitik we have already
told you how Sweden is also having serious
problems with violence. In this country,
for example, police have identified more
than 30,000 people who are either part of or
have close connections to the more than 50 gangs
that have triggered violence within the country.
("We have never faced such ruthless criminality
[...] The organizational model of the entire
Swedish justice system is not prepared to
deal with such extensive criminality" – Anders
Thornberg, Chief of the Swedish National Police)
And watch out for Belgium or even Germany. In
the great European power, the number of crimes
has skyrocketed... This has caused the voting
intentions of the far-right Alternative
for Germany party to shoot up as well.
In total, of the 27 governments of the European
Union, only six currently lean to the left. And
there may soon be even fewer. In the last 18
months there has been a tremendous political
shift across Europe. And here immigration
and above all the problems of integration
are playing an absolutely fundamental role.
So, at this point, the key question is over
to you: How would you tackle France's
problems? Immigration is essential and,
what’s more, it has very positive economic
effects, but how can we improve the integration
of the first and, above all, the second
and third generations of immigrants?
Leave me your answer in the comments and
let's open a debate. And now if you found
this video interesting don't forget to
like and subscribe to VisualPolitik.
Thank you very much for being there,
All the best and see you next time.